what are your odds on your next
presidents day let's say maybe
twenty-five or thirty percent how do you
feel about the David Duke Kwazii
endorsement I don't need his endorsement
I certainly wouldn't want his
endorsement I don't need anybody's
indoors I'm not looking to repudiate
David sure I would do that if it made
you feel better I would certainly reboot
I don't know anything about him this guy
is now the front-runner he should be
held to account just like me he should
be asked as he was yesterday how are you
gonna pay for it did he seem low energy
there no I cheated a little bit more
dynamic yeah you know you can't force
that and it was a little bit forced I
guess he's trying very hard because I
used the term low energy he is a
low-energy person by nature and that's
okay there's nothing wrong with that he
got a little tangled up in this question
about anchor babies r arable what do you
think he's gotten wrong about that he
took the Hispanics and all of a sudden
he changed Hispanics and Mexicans with
the asians and now the Asian community
is furious at him and they're really
angry at him somewhere that's not a
phrase that you have any hesitancy about
using throughout this campaign no I'm
using it nobody's complained about it
when i use it they complain about it
because they don't expect he would be
using that did you recall who you
support in 1992 i actually liked ross
perot a lot i thought he was great and
then I think he went off a little bit
off the deep end I will say this had he
not existed you don't you're not talking
about Bill Clinton then you're not
worried about Hillary's vote right now I
don't know i think i'd probably voted
for bush you don't remember which of
those three you're not clear but i do
remember i don't like to talk about who
i voted for in this case i voted for
bush 2000 core versus the other bush if
you remember who you support it in that
election bush when i talk about the
bible is very personal so I don't want
to get into sales I don't want to get
into there's no it means a lot to you
that you think about our site the Bible
means a lot to me but I don't want to
get into specifics an Old Testament guy
or do Testament probably equal I think
it's just an incredible the whole Bible
is an incredible I joke very much so
they always hold up the art of the day I
say my second favorite book of all time
do you believe that Lee Harvey Oswald
acted alone
I believe he acted alone yes is there
someone out there today who you say
isn't on the court but say this is the
kind of person i would consider for the
court I don't want to mention names I
think it's inappropriate to mention
names and certainly at this stage you
know so early and long way to go my
sister's great i have a sister who's on
the court of appeals and she's fantastic
side be a good supreme i notice i think
she would be phenomenal i think she'd be
one of the best but frankly I think she
is we'll have to rule that out now at
least have bro but I do have a sister
who's very smart and a very good person